joy is with us in Grand Junction I joy
are you hi I'm so well Dave thanks so
much for taking my call sure baby is on
my back and she's sick awaiting her a
little bit sorry about that
bye well I read the first half of little
money makeover about six years ago paid
off all of our debt my husband and I and
our now four kids
and apparently you should read the
second half because we failed to save
for an emergency and the emergency hit
about six months ago and we quickly
accumulated about $35,000 in debt and so
what I'm wondering right now is whether
or not we should sell our home we have
quite a bit of equity
what is your home income it's about 60
to 70 my husband's a teacher with a lot
of side hustles how much did you pay off
how much debt did you pay off the first
time
23000 how long did that take took us
about two years this is going to take
three do you like your house we love it
then keep it what kind of emergency
$35,000 on medical medical our car died
and our last work due to a medical
situation how much do you owe on your
car 16,000 Oh sell it okay I thought you
would say that no well yeah you knew
what to do you just didn't want to do it
yeah it's up to you kiddo you can do
what you want to do you're growing up
but this is what we teach people to do
basically like you said you did the plan
ish and you didn't follow through and
you didn't have an emergency fund in
place and then you got freaked out and
went and bought a car in the middle of
having a medical problem and a job
layoff and so you don't get to make
decisions based on emotions if you're
going to win with money you get to make
me you can have unless their emotions of
joy
those are the only thing money decisions
you can make but freak out always every
single time I get desperate I get stupid
right after that they follow each other
around that broke desperate and stupid
their three brothers and hang out
together and none of them are smart
it's like they're on this other brother
Darryl right and I've been that I've
been right where you are kiddo I get
scared and then I get desperate and then
I get stupid and it just fear is not a
fruit of the Spirit and even if I get
afraid and everybody does I've just have
steeled myself against making decisions
based on the fear and that car purchase
was not necessary and you know it now
you could have gotten the car you might
have getting that you may need it a
different car the car crashed I got that
or whatever happened here but you didn't
need that car and you guys went
overboard and so sell it undo the
problem and oh by the way that's 15,000
of the 35 tada
we're back to 20 and that's what I would
do if I were you you do what you want to
do but you called me